this revolution remains undimmed if
anything it's growing thousands upon
thousands are still on the streets of
Khartoum in a show of raucous
celebration and utter determination
they've got more than they expected but
now they want the lot the complete
overthrow of the military regime here
and a new civilian Council of leaders
that could be difficult to achieve
Mohammed naji al Assam is one of the
youthful leaders of this revolution
three months of this year he's been in
prison he's only just out he's a proper
Stannah continuingly stopped for
pictures when he joined him at the
centre of the demonstration he concedes
there is a long way to go and the army
remain dangerous to their cause each day
passing by we know that the military is
getting more and more powerful and we we
don't want this to happen that's why we
are staying on our stance now because if
the military feel they can remove you
remove this they will yeah you still
fear that everything will get as it was
before the coalition of opposition
groups are negotiating with the military
but these demonstrations are organized
by the street
volunteers man the barricades everyone
is searched
trying to get to the center of the
demonstration and they run their own
security doctors our nurses man a
24-hour emergency hospital where they
saved and lost protesters shaft in the
days before President Omar al-bashir was
overthrown by his own military this is a
people's uprising and it's noticeable
how many women are fully involved
constantly keeping a vigil on the
streets and organizing the loot
[Music]
and young female doctors protesters as
it stands there's been no official
comment from the military but they're
being warned even more people will take
to the streets soon and the process
leaders remain at loggerheads over faces
surrounded by military still this
revolution is far from finished yet
certainly the military are everywhere
guarding intersections and guarding the
revolution they say from other units who
may want to reverse the remarkable
changes here nobody is comfortable being
surrounded by these heavily armed and
equipped security services who brutally
control the country for so long but they
are here what's different now though is
that the people are as well mr. Ramji
Sky News Khartoum